[संगीत]
खुदा
है तो हेलो आप सभी लोग मैं हूं और विकास
केवल ए गया हूं दे सेवन लेकर अभी तीन ही
जाने आए हैं सो थोड़ा सा वेट कर लेते हैं
ताकि और
सब लोग देख सके लाइव में
क्वेश्चंस रहेंगे
और ए जाए
जो लोग मेरे से बर हो गए हैं और एकदम एकदम
परेशान है मेरे से की मैं क्यों ए जाता
हूं रोज रोज लेकर आज उनके खुशखबरी है मेरा
लास्ट यही है उसके बाद आप लोगों की
रिक्वेस्ट पर ही आऊंगा तो आप लोग चाहे की
कुछ और भी पढ़ना है पटना है तो अब क्या
बोलूं
चालू करते हैं
ठीक है तो हो आप लोग को मेरे स्क्रीन दिखे
रहा होगा
तो पहले तो एक फोल्डर में बना देता हूं
अपना न्यू
फोल्डर अपना
क्वेश्चन पेपर मकर
[संगीत]
अपना इस पर
यह देखो इस फोल्डर
क्रिएट करना चाहे किसी भी एडिट वगैरा करना
चाहे तो इजीली अपन यहां पे कर सकते हैं तो
सीन नहीं होगा यहां पर अपना
जिन लोगों के नहीं ए रहा है वो लोग टेंशन
नहीं करना है यहां पर ऊपर क्लिक करना यहां
पर ओपन फोल्डर पे क्लिक करना फोल्डर क्लिक
हो जाएगा फाइल पे क्लिक करोगे तो फाइल पे
फाइल ओपन हो जाएगी बट एवं फोल्डर क्लिक
करेंगे तो हां एकदम स्क्रैच से चालू करने
वाले हैं तो उसको थोड़ा गैरों से की आप
लोग को दिखे
स्क्रीन ज्यादा ही बड़ा हो गया मेरे को ना
दिक्कत हो जाए
रिटायरमेंट
मैंने क्वेश्चंस ठीक
होकर क्वेश्चन पेपर बन जाए
ठीक है और उसको अपना क्वेश्चन जो है वह
मैन्युअल इंटर करना चाहता है वो और एक
फाइल भी इनपुट करना चाहता है
ठीक है
तो और साथ ही के अंदर उसके एक और
रिटायरमेंट है यहां पर की वही मैं अलग-अलग
सेट्स भी बना सुकून
ठीक है तो मां लो ये कर रिटायरमेंट है
उसकी अपने क्लाइंट की की मुझे ऐसा
क्वेश्चन पेपर चाहिए देखो अभी जब ये
ऑनलाइन कितना है वो हो रहा था क्या कहते
हैं अपना
क्वेश्चन पेपर्स मतलब उनको बनाने थे की
इतने सारे
पर क्योंकि एक क्वेश्चन पेपर सबको देंगे
तो फिर चीटिंग होना कितना इजी से हो जाएगा
ऑनलाइन के अंदर कौन मोइटिंग कर रहा है बट
अगर सबको अलग-अलग क्वेश्चन दिए जाए की मां
लो की एक क्लास में 10 बच्चे आपके पास 100
क्वेश्चंस है है ना तो 29 बच्चों को
अलग-अलग डिस्कस क्वेश्चंस आए हैं या मतलब
10 क्वेश्चंस भी आए तो अलग-अलग 10
क्वेश्चन आया है और उनको भी नहीं पता की
क्या क्वेश्चंस आने वाले हैं जो एग्जामिनर
उनको खुद को भी नहीं पता होगी की क्या
मतलब जो अपना पेपर बना रहा है उसको भी
नहीं पता होगी की क्या क्वेश्चंस आने वाले
हैं तो चीटिंग का कोई चेस नहीं बंता है इस
बार इस टाइप के क्वेश्चन पेपर मकर के अंदर
तो अपन एक यूनिट टाइप के क्वेश्चन पेपर
मकर बनाने वाले हैं ऐसा नॉर्मल ही कुछ भी
नहीं की ये दाल दिया ये दाल दिया एक बन के
ए जाएगा मत आराम से वैसे अपन नहीं करने
वाले हैं अपन यूनिक से बनाएंगे कुछ
क्योंकि भाई अपन लोग दफन एक से बाढ़ रहा
है ठीक है तो डेफिनेशन कम तो हटके ही
रहेगा हमेशा कोई ऐसे नॉर्मल कम नहीं करते
तो वैसे ही अपना चलेगा
सब कुछ क्या सीन है अब होता है की अपनी
तरफ से आप इसके लॉजिक कैसे बनाएंगे तो
सबसे पहले मां लो की अगर एक क्वेश्चन पेपर
डिजाइन करना है तो क्वेश्चन नंबर डिजाइन
करते हैं यहां पर ये मां लो एक अपना पेपर
है
ठीक है ना एक क्वेश्चन पेपर कैसा हो सकता
है यहां पर अपने इंस्टिट्यूट का नियम
वगैरा आता है
ठीक है ना यहां पर अपना सेट्स लिखे हुए
आते हैं की यार कौन सा वाला सेट है आपका
यहां पर टोटल मार्क्स लिखे हुए आते हैं
फिर यहां पर एक नंबर एक नंबर वाले
क्वेश्चन एक नंबर वाले क्वेश्चंस का ये है
क्वेश्चन नंबर वन तू फिर दो मार्क्स वाले
अपने वन तू देखो मेरी राइटिंग बहुत खराब
है मैं फिर भी कोशिश कर रहा हूं उससे
लिखने का मेरी रियल में भी राइटिंग इतनी
खराब है तो माउस कैसे ए रही होगी मैं खुद
भी नहीं समझ पाऊंगा फिर भी ठीक है आप लोग
कोशिश करो थोड़ा सा मैसेज
ठीक है सेकंड चीज सेट तो पर खुद से
बताएंगे
बट कितने सेट चाहिए वो अपन को पूछना है
ठीक है तो सेट्स के लिए अपन को पूछना है
इधर से टोटल मार्क्स अपन खुद से बता देंगे
भाई ठीक है ना और साथ में ये एक नंबर वाले
क्योंकि ये क्वेश्चन पेपर के अंदर देखो
कितने में मार्क्स के क्वेश्चंस होते हैं
एक नंबर का होता है दो नंबर का जो तीन
नंबर का होता है कर नंबर का होता है फास्ट
नंबर का होता है 10 नंबर का होता है ठीक
है ऐसा राहत है तो ये अपन खुद से डिफाइन
कर देंगे वो दिक्कत की बात नहीं है देखो
यूजर से जितना कम पूछोगे ना उतना ज्यादा
बढ़िया होता है
क्योंकि यूजर को ज्यादा कोशिश का आंसर
देने का मां नहीं करता
इतने क्वेश्चन इतने क्वेश्चन पूछ रहा हूं
मैं कैसे करेंगे
क्वेश्चन बैंक बनाएंगे
रेंडम लाइब्रेरी होती है जो अपन उसे करने
वाले हैं उसके अंदर
तो उसके बड़े में बना कर देखेंगे और साथ
में तीसरी चीज क्या तीसरा क्या रिटायरमेंट
था की भाई वो फाइल भी दाल सके तो फाइल के
लिए अपन को फाइल हैंडलिंग करनी पड़ेगी जो
क्वेश्चन लेक्चर से मैंने कराई थी शायद
पर्सनल लेक्चर में मैंने फाइनल लिंक कराई
थी तो यह सब चीज को ओपन को दिमाग में रखना
का है ठीक है ना
तो ठीक है
तो सबसे पहले
बना लेते हैं
उसके बाद में अपन चाहते हैं की यूजर से
अपन पूछते रहे की
आप कितना मतलब कितने क्वेश्चन जाना चाहते
हो कहां क्वेश्चन डालना चाहते हो तो उसके
लिए अपन क्या करेंगे अपन एक इसके अंदर लूप
चला कर रखते हैं की जो बार-बार पूछते
रहेगा की मैं आपको क्वेश्चन
को यूजर को भी नहीं पता होगा की कितने लोग
क्वेश्चन सेंटर करने वाले हैं क्योंकि वो
क्वेश्चन बैंक है पूरा ठीक है तो उससे
पूछेंगे
पड़े तो उन सब चीजों से बचाने के लिए अपन
एक इंटरफेस बनाएंगे जिसके अंदर एक अपन
ऑप्शन रखेंगे की यार अपना आपको क्वेश्चन
इंटर करना है क्या करना है तो वन दबाव
नहीं करना है तो तू से एक जीरो
ठीक है
तब तक ये लोग चलेगा जब तक बांदा एग्जिट
नहीं कर देता
प्रिंट होगा अपना पहले
इंटर क्वेश्चन
और दूसरे अपना
फिर अपन इन फूल ले लेंगे उससे
24 करके इन
फोटो
तो यहां पर लिखेंगे प्रिंट
व्हाट्सएप कुछ आवाज ए रहा है
ठीक है तो इतना तो क्लियर हो गया कब होगा
जब वह 2 या 2 के अलावा कुछ भी दाल देगा तो
मतलब कुछ बन के अलावा कुछ भी डालेगा ना तू
भी अपना ये लूप ब्रेक हो जाएगा
ठीक है
तो उसके बाद में उसके सामने क्या आना
चाहिए अब ऊपर उसके सामने ये पूछते हैं की
भाई तुमको कितने मार्क्स का क्वेश्चन इंटर
करने का है ठीक है
तो
इंग्लिश
क्वेश्चन आपको
डालना है
1234 5110
टोटल मास्क मार्क्स
ये पूछ रहे हैं की
आपको कितने नंबर का क्वेश्चन डालने का है
मतलब एक नंबर के क्वेश्चन डालने आपको दो
नंबर के क्वेश्चंस डालना है आपको तीन नंबर
के क्वेश्चंस डालने आपको क्योंकि अपन क्या
कर रहे हैं की
अपने करें ना की एक नंबर के उसको जितने भी
क्वेश्चन मालूम है ना सर वो लिख देगा दो
नंबर के कितने भी क्वेश्चन चाहता है ना वो
होता है लिख देगा तीन नंबर के वो कितने भी
क्वेश्चन चाहते हैं उतने लिख देगा मतलब
जितने भी उसको क्वेश्चन आते हैं ना वो लिख
देगा सारे दोस्तों तीन से जितने क्वेश्चन
आते हैं सारे लिख देगा वो ठीक उसमें लिखने
के बाद में क्या होगा ना बाद में वो अपन
को ये बताया की मुझे एक नंबर के कितने
क्वेश्चन चाहिए दो नंबरी कितने की हनी
चाहिए मां लो एक नंबर के 100 क्वेश्चन
सेंटर की है ठीक है ना 100 क्वेश्चन इंटर
करने के बाद में उसको चाहिए से 100 में से
दो क्वेश्चन सी है
तो उसे कैसे में अपना
प्रोग्राम्स के अंदर में से रैंडम कोई भी
दो क्वेश्चन उठा के अपने पेपर में दाल
देगा
ठीक है तो यह अपना प्रोग्राम करेगा
बेसिकली
कम करते हैं
अब अपन क्या पूछेगी उधर फाइल डालनी है की
आपको क्वेश्चंस
मैन्युअल इंटर करने की एक क्वेश्चन खुद से
हुए
तीसरा क्वेश्चन
का फाइल बना रखा है उसे फाइल के अंदर में
से उठाएंगे ठीक है
ओपन
यहां पर फाइल और यह पहले से अपना रीड मोड
में खुलेगा
सॉरी
अच्छा
इसका प्रोडक्ट
क्वेश्चंस एक नंबर के डालने ठीक है
तो अब अपन क्या करेंगे ना इन आउटपुट का
कहानी पे से करवा लेते हैं अपन ठीक है ना
ताकि क्या रहेगा ना की अपने देखो
और भी क्वेश्चन से एक नंबर के तो फिर से
प्रोग्राम चलता है चलने के बाद में मतलब
वो फिर से अपना ही लूप में जाता है लूप
में जान का तो क्या करेंगे एक नंबर की और
क्वेश्चन लेने तो वो एक जगह पे जाके से
होने चाहिए तो मैं एक कम करता हूं मैं एक
यहां पर एक
डिक्शनरी क्रिएट कर लेट हूं
ठीक है तो यह बन गया इसका मतलब है
देखना ना पड़े कुछ भी ऐसा अब थोड़ा अच्छा
सा ग रहा है अपना आउटपुट
यहां पर इसका ठीक है अपना
क्वेश्चन बैंक
के अंदर का जो की है
इसको कल करूंगा
ठीक है
अब देखो इस जगह पर एक
ब्लॉक लगा देता हूं
एक्सेप्शन से होते हुए एरर वाले वेरिएबल
के अंदर जाके से हो जाएगा जो एरर आएगा तो
अपन बाद में प्रिंट कर सकते हैं लेकिन
उससे अपना प्रोग्राम टर्मिनेट नहीं होगा
ठीक है तो अगर प्रिंट करेंगे इसको
समथिंग
स्ट्रिंग को अगर अपन को लिखना होता है
तो इधर ही चेंज हो जाएंगे आपको कोमल लगा
के एक्स्ट्रा लिखने की जरूर नहीं पड़ेगी
इसके आगे मैं और भी कोई दिखता हूं लिख
सकता हूं
चलो
यहां पर
इनपुट
ठीक है
सीधा अपेंड कर देंगे
अगर फाइल पीएनजी का हुआ तो क्या होगा
मैंने पहले वाले उसके नाम बताया था तो
वहां पर ही एरर दिखा देगा
यहां पर इसकी जो मोड है उसको तो उसके बाद
में वो बाइनरी रीड करेगा क्योंकि जो इमेज
होती है वो अपनी गैलरी फाइल होती है इमेज
की तो टैक्सी फाइल लगा नहीं तो फिर
यहां पर अपना समथिंग
क्वेश्चंस डबल इक्वल तू तू करके या फिर
मुझे मैप से आना यही चीज यहां पे वापस
डालना पड़ेगा ठीक है ना इसको कॉपी करके
फिर इसके अंदर डालो
ठीक है चेंज होगा यहां पर तू मार्क्स
कितना पड़ेगा मुझे तो है ना ये ना अभी
देखो दो के लिए करना पड़ेगा क्वेश्चन 2 3
4 5 10 इनके लिए अलग-अलग करने पढ़ेंगे तो
उसकी जगह पे मैं क्या करूंगा ना यहां पर
एक फंक्शन क्रिएट कर दूंगा इसके ऊपर यहां
पर करता हूं अपना लेफ्ट
क्वेश्चन
टेक के नाम से
जिसके अंदर मेरा राहत हूं अभी देखो ये ऐसे
थोड़ा सा आगे से ए गया तो देखो अगर कभी भी
अगर आप कैसे टाइप ए गया ए गया ए जाए आपको
पीछे करना पड़े तो एक-एक को लेकर पीछे मत
जाना स्विफ्ट दबाते रहना तो वो अपने आप
पूरे को लेकर पीछे ए जाएगा ठीक है अब इसके
अंदर क्वेश्चन बैंक वाले
नीचे इसका मतलब ये है की वेरिएबल नहीं
करता है फंक्शन के अंदर क्योंकि अपना ये
तो फंक्शन बना ये जो वेरिएबल बना हुआ है
ये में फंक्शन के अंदर लोकल
को मैं ग्लोबल बना था तो ये हर फंक्शन इस
वेरिएबल को एक्सेस कर पता लेकिन अभी
फंक्शन लोकली बना हुआ है तो इसलिए मुझे ये
करना पड़ेगा ये इसको पास करना पड़ेगा इसके
अंदर
जब मैं आगे इसको कॉलिंग करूंगा
तो मैं इसके उसमें दाल देता हूं
इसके पैरामीटर क्वेश्चन बैंक करके
पैरामीटर दाल देता हूं उसका एक
क्वेश्चन बैंक
के दौरान
सीधा क्वेश्चन टेक वाले को कल करेंगे
[संगीत]
वन मार्क तू मार्क
एस
ठीक
है
सही सॉरी मैंने इसको गलत जगह पे लिख दिया
मुझे यहां पर लिखने का था उसको
जो मैंने वहां पर लिख दिया कोई बात नहीं
तो यहां पर फाइंड के अंदर आप दाल देते हैं
24 करके और नीचे रिप्लाई
जी व्हाट्सएप को रिप्लेस करना है वो भी कर
सकते थे
यहां पर लिख सकते हैं
फ्रेंड
करता है तो फिर अपना यह वाला फंक्शन कल
होगा
की आपको फाइल पट करनी है की मेमोरी डालने
का है फाइल पट करने की तो फाइल के लोकेशन
के अंदर इस लिस्ट के अंदर और नहीं तो फिर
यहां पर दिखा देगा ड्रम करके और उसके बाद
में अपना ये दिखाएगा अपना की अगर क्वेश्चन
मैन्युअल इंटर करना एक दो क्वेश्चन है तो
मैन्युअल इंटर करो यहां पर फिर उसे
मैन्युअल क्वेश्चन और तक करने के बाद में
उसको अपेंड कर देगा लिस्ट के अंदर अपन
क्या होता है ये सब मैंने पहले बताया हुआ
है तो कुछ भी अभी तक कुछ भी ऐसा नया ऐसा
नहीं है इसलिए मैं क्वेश्चन पेपर को थोड़ा
ज्यादा फोर्स कर रहा था क्योंकि इसके अंदर
अपना पहले के जो भी कॉन्सेप्ट है ना वो
सारे रिवाइज हो रहे होंगे अगर आप इस चीज
को देख रहे हो तो आपको समझ में ए रहा है
की यार पहले जो कुछ भी सिखाया था वो एक एक
चीज यहां पर रिवाइज हो रहा है
अगर जल्दी-जल्दी लोगों को ऐसा लगता है वो
चाट में लिख दो की हां भाई ऐसा ही है या
फिर आपको ऐसा ग रहा है
बहुत बेकार सा बता रहे हो तो वो भी अपना
नीचे लिख दो
ठीक है
ठीक है तो अभी इसके आगे क्या रहेगा ना की
क्वेश्चन वाला अपना हो गया अब अपन चेक
करते हैं की अब हमको यूजर से पूछना है की
आपको एक नंबर के कितने क्वेश्चन चाहिए दो
नंबर के कितने क्वेश्चन किया तीन नंबर के
किस लिए क्वेश्चन चाहिए क्योंकि अभी देखो
जितने भी उसने क्वेश्चन डालने थे वो सारे
उसने इसमें लिख दिए हैं
ठीक है
दाल दिए हैं अब उसने 100 क्वेश्चन डेल
होंगे तो 100 में से उसको दो चाहिए रहेंगे
तो उसके लिए अपने को पूछना पड़ेगा ना की
भाई आपने कितने चाहिए करके ठीक है ना तो
अगर मां लो एग्जिट करता है तो लूप के वैसे
एवं बाहर जाना है
ठीक है तो लूप केवल बाहर ही कम करता है
उसके बाद में यहां पे उससे पूछता है
रहेंगे तो अपन एक नंबर के लिए पूछेंगे ना
की भाई आपको एक नंबरी कितने चाहिए अगर
उसने दो नंबर के क्वेश्चन इंटर कर रहे
रहेंगे तो ये अपन पूछेंगे नहीं की आपने दो
नंबर ही कितने चाहिए तो उसके लिए अपन क्या
करेंगे ना अपन है ना चेक करेंगे की भाई ये
वाला तो अपना लिस्ट है इसके अंदर का ये
क्वेश्चन
लेंथ क्या है अगर मां लो इसकी लेंथ जीरो
से ज्यादा निकलते है मतलब उसमें एक चीज है
या दो चीज है तीन चीज है अगर एक भी चीज है
तो पूछेगा नहीं आपको एक चीज है तो आपको एक
चीज चाहिए की नहीं यहां पे नहीं चाहिए तो
फिर कुछ भी मत करो
है ना
एवरीथिंग इस फाइल तिल नो प्रिंस
का इस्तेमाल करके जो भी मैंने बताया था
और इसके लेंथ अगर बड़ी होती है जीरो से तो
ये पूछेगा प्रेस से की
अपने कम करते हैं
तो q1
क्वेश्चन नंबर
क्वेश्चंस
यू नीड ऑफ
टुमारो
और एक और अपना
इस प्रोग्राम में गलती
इसमें गलतियां गलती क्या है
अलिफ
इन तीन में से कोई एक ही रन हुआ
इस कैसे में क्या चाहिए
हो सके तो
एक भी रन नहीं होना चाहिए
देखो
हो सकता है
मैंने नहीं बताई होगी तो अभी वापस अगर बता
रहा हूं
अगर देखो इसकी कंडीशन ट्रू होगी तो ये
फ्रंट होगा अगर ट्रू नहीं होगी
ठीक है
ठीक है ना अब इस कैसे में अलग-अलग देने
पढ़ेंगे
क्वेश्चन चाहिए उसके हिसाब से अपन को है
ना वो भी करना पड़ेगा ना टोटलिंग भी करनी
पड़ेगी टोटलिंग करने के लिए फॉर्मूला अपन
नीचे लिखेंगे फॉर्मूला
जैसे q1 लिखने हैं यहां पर ये फिर q2 करते
हैं इसको q3 q4 q5 और q10
ठीक है
ना मैं एक कम करता हूं की पहले वो देता
हूं
पहले से इसका इनका रिलेशनशिप
मां लो उसने यहां में से एक भी क्वेश्चन
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं किया तो एक भी क्वेश्चन
नहीं डेल तो उसके बाद में उसने एग्जिट कर
दिया बिना क्वेश्चन कोई डायलॉग
बनाने जाएंगे
ये देखो q1 वेरिएबल है अगर मां लो की वो
q1 के अंदर दाल देता है
तू दोनों में तो 224 हो जाएगा
ठीक
है
टोटल
ग्रेटर डेन जीरो
अपने चेक लिस्ट के अंदर क्या-क्या कम होगा
अभी तक अपन ने इस सीट का नाम करवा दिया
अपना वो हो गया क्या
इंटर करवा दिया है ठीक है साथ के अंदर अपन
ने अपना क्या नाम है
कौन-कौन से क्वेश्चन कितने मार्क्स चाहिए
वो भी बता दिया टोटलिंग भी अपन ने कर दी
है सेट्स का कम बाकी है और क्वेश्चन पेपर
बनाने का कम बाकी है और उनको रेंडम रखिए
ठीक है
करते हैं
कम चालू होना चाहिए
ठीक है
यहां पर लिख दिया
समझ जाओगे
सेट से डालता हूं यहां पर
आने के चांसेस है
और देखो|
मतलब कुछ चलना आप रोड भी का सकते हैं तो
यहां पर भी अपना एरर आने के चांसेस है तो
अपन यहां पर भी इसको ट्राई करके
इस्तेमाल करेंगे
अब पता है आप लोगों को अभी इसके अंदर भी
एक टास्क मिलने वाला है ठीक है ना वह आगे
बताऊंगा
उसको कैसे करना होगा
नंबर एप्स
नहीं करूंगा
रीड मोड में नहीं चल रहा है
एफ डॉट क्लोज भी कर देते हैं
चलो एक बार अपने देखते की इतना अपना कैसा
ग रहा है प्रोग्राम
कहां था यह
कितने बजे
तीन चाहिए
किया तो था ऊपर
मैंने
जीरो ये देखो मैंने वेरिएबल को जो पटाया
था तो मैंने आपको इस चीज के बड़े में नहीं
बताया था बट टीचेज मैक्स के अंदर भी बहुत
आम सी होती है की आईएफ a=b और बी = सी तो
अल्टरनेटली इसे इक्वल तू सी ये चीज के
बड़े में आपने मैक्स के अंदर बड़ा रहेगा
10 तक के तो आई ही आई है 10th के ऊपर
कितनी कोई कम नहीं है जैसे बताओ इंडिया
में सभी पड़ता है
एडिट करता हूं अब अगर
दोनों मा गया
यहां पर
फाइल बन के आनी चाहिए जो आई है की नहीं वो
चेक करते हैं
की नहीं
उसमें क्या लिख कर आया है
हो जाएगा
इलेक्ट्रॉनिक
[संगीत]
ठीक है तो यह जीरो नंबर क्या है
एक नंबर का है
चलो
बीच में लिखा हुआ है तो देखो बीच में करने
के लिए सीरियसली होता है पाइथन में से कुछ
नहीं आता है इसके अंदर की अपन कैसे इसको
बीच में कर सके तो अपन फिर भी अपन जुगाड़
हुआ आदमी अपन डायरेक्ट से बाढ़ रहा है तो
अपन बीच में लेकर आएंगे इसको तो एक कम
करते हैं इसके अंदर सबसे पहले तो एक्स
स्टिंगरा इस्तेमाल कर लेते हैं
ठीक है
और इसको अवेलेबल है
अच्छा डिजाइन
वाले फंक्शन के अंदर इंस्टिट्यूट था वो
लोग के लिए बना हुआ था ग्लोबल नहीं बना
हुआ है वो बट अपन को ये देखो यहां पर वाला
यह वाला जो है
तो इस वाले फंक्शन
करते हैं
यहां पर थोड़ा बीच में लिखकर आया
ठीक है
अभी सेट कौन सा है
बांदा
करेंगे
तो देखो
इंप्रूवमेंट
के अंदर ठीक है
टोटल
यहां पर टोटल
उसके बाद में लिखेंगे एफ डॉट
राइट
फॉलोइंग
होगा क्वेश्चन
और
अच्छा ग रहा है
की नहीं है
की मैं ऐसी कोई सर्विस
सिक्योरिटी का चल रहा है प्रोजेक्ट कोई और
ही चल रहा है
अपना
क्वेश्चंस कितने चाहिए
उतने वाले लोग चलना चाहिए और लूप में क्या
रहेगा ना
अपने क्वेश्चंस का तो पूरा बैंक है मतलब
जी लिस्ट के अंदर अपने क्वेश्चंस पढ़े हुए
हैं उसे लिस्ट में से रैंडम एक क्वेश्चन
उठेगी
ठीक है
ओके सॉरी इन रेंज
बताइए
है तो उसके लिए कहना चीज होती है
ना की अपना कोई भी लिस्ट में से
लिस्ट में से कोई रेंडम आपको दिखता है
इतना ही कम है इसका तो बस अपन भी अपने पास
एक लिस्ट है ऐसे फ्रेंड इंटरव्यू होता है
बहुत साड़ी चीज भी होती है तो रेंडम की
आपका एक टास्क तो ये है की आपको रेंडम
लोरी के बड़े में और पता करने का है
देखो अभी तक आपने किसी लाइब्रेरी के ऊपर
डिपेंडेंट होकर नहीं लिखा है
इसके अंदर
लिखूंगा
अच्छा अब स्ट्रिंग देखो अभी यहां पर एरर
क्या हुआ ना मैं आपको यहां पर वो दिखता
हूं की क्या सीन हुआ है अभी इसके अंदर
यहां पर क्यों दिखा रहा है
उसको तो अपन इस कैसे में क्या करेंगे की
अपने इस चाचा को बोलेंगे
की चाचा जी कम करो सिंगल कोड बादल जो
ठीक है
ओके अभी आगे गलती ए जाएगी अपने
गलती है की नहीं
अपना एरर आता है
शायद अभी सही हो गया है मैं नेटवर्क चेंज
करने वाला था
उससे पहले से ही हो गया हो तो अच्छी बात
है
उसके चक्कर में हां तो अभी कम करेंगे अपन
की कुछ क्वेश्चन मांग लेट हूं की मैं उसके
बाद पूरे क्वेश्चन हो तो
और कॉफी उसके बाद थोड़ी सी और क्वेश्चंस
हैं तो मैं इसमें से कॉपी ले लेट हूं कॉपी
चलो ठीक है
डिफ्लोरेंस
डालूंगा
कमर के दर्पण q3 दाल देते हैं अपना
ठीक है हो गया
तो एक नंबर क्या मुझे एक ही क्वेश्चन
चाहिए ठीक है अब दो नंबर के मुझे दो ही
क्वेश्चन चाहिए तीन नंबर के मुझे दो ही
क्वेश्चन चाहिए
तो गैस यहां पर ये 10 रहेगा ये इस चक्कर
में के अंदर यहां पे दो बट टूल तू लिख कर
आए क्योंकि एक और अपने 10 नंबर का था 10
नंबर का था अपना तो ये यहां पे तू ही लिखा
मैंने छोड़ दिया गलती से यहां पे 10 आएगा
तो अपना सही चल रहा है तो इसको
तो हो मनी सेट्स वे नीड दबाएंगे
ठीक है
फोनिक्स
से हुई
आईएफ यू हद तो डिस्क्राइब योरसेल्फ
q1 के अंदर क्या था ये देखो
पहले वो नहीं था|
की आपको
प्लस सिक्योरिटी
नहीं आया
प्रोग्राम में कोई दिक्कत की बात नहीं है
और इसके अंदर उसने दोनों सेक्सी उठाया है
अब अगर अपन को इस चीज को ओवरकम करना होगा
तो अपन कैसे करेंगे ना की अपन ने जो
क्वेश्चंस लिए हैं उनको एक अपन फिनिश करना
दाल देंगे की भाई ये वाला क्वेश्चन लिस्ट
में दाल दिया है फिर चेक करेंगे की भाई जो
क्वेश्चन है अगला क्वेश्चन उठाया है क्या
वो पहले था की नहीं क्योंकि अपने
पैरेललोग्राम के क्वेश्चन था वो एक लिस्ट
में दाल के रखा है अपन अपन उसे लिस्ट से
चेक करेंगे की भाई ये वाला क्वेश्चन जो
नया क्वेश्चन आया है जिसके अंदर था की
नहीं अगर जिसके करण नहीं होगा तो अच्छी
बात है है तो फिर रिकॉर्ड डिलीट कर फिर वो
चेक करेंगे वो भी हुआ तो एक और जेनरेट कर
फिर वो चेक करेंगे तब तो जेनरेट कर तब तक
उसके अंदर जो उसके अंदर लिस्ट वाला जो
अपना क्वेश्चंस है वो उसके अंदर ना हो
ठीक है
तो ये चीज है ना आपको ट्राई करके बतानी है
अगर आपसे अगर ऐसा हो रहा है की यार नहीं
भाई हार्दिक भाई ये सेल मेरे से नहीं हो
का रहा है तो उसके लिए कुछ नहीं आप लोग
टेलीग्राम पे आना है की भाई हार्दिक भाई
ये हो गया है ऐसा इसको कैसे
एक ब्लॉक को कोड हमारे टेलीग्राम प्रोवाइड
कर दूंगा बट ये आपका टास्क है ठीक है ना
देखो क्वेश्चन पेपर के अंदर ये देखो सेट
नंबर वन है और हमें सेट नंबर तू चेक करता
हूं
यह देखो सेट नंबर वन
ठीक है
दोनों के अंदर अलग-अलग क्वेश्चंस रहेंगे
क्योंकि अपन ने रेंडम का उसे किया है ठीक
है ना अगर देखो कभी-कभी से ए रहा है तो
मैंने उसके लिए बताया की भाई जो क्वेश्चन
आपका पहले निकाला उसको इंग्लिश में से करो
फिर जो दूसरे क्वेश्चन लेकर उसको चेक कर
रहे हो पुराने वाले इसके अंदर है की नहीं
अगर नहीं है लिस्ट के अंदर तो ही वो अपने
यहां पर लिखा है तो फिर ना दिखाएं ये आपका
टास्क है तो मैंने आपको दो तास दिए हैं ये
सबसे पहले तो अगर रैंडम दोनों से क्वेश्चन
ए रहे हैं तो उसको ओवरकम करने का मैंने
बता दिया मैं नोटपैड में लिख देता हूं और
पद के अंदर अपना तास नंबर एक है आपका
की
रेंडम
लाइव के
बड़े में सब कुछ
पता करो ठीक है
ओवरकम थिस शो
मैंने इसका तरीका बता दिया मैं फिर से
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं
आपको बस एग्जीक्यूशन करना है फिर भी
दिक्कत आई है टेलीग्राम पे आओ बताओ वहां
पर ऐसे टेस्ट में प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा ठीक
है
जो नेट हो रहा है उसको इंग्लिश में लिस्ट
में अपना पेंट करवा दो फिर चेक करो की भाई
लिस्ट के अंदर है की नहीं अगर नहीं है तो
फिर ठीक है भाई उसको अपना राइट कर दो फाइल
के अंदर अगर वो लिस्ट के अंदर है तो उसके
बाद में नया नोट करो तब तक नया जिनित करो
तब तक अपना लिस्ट वाला नहीं होता तो अपन
अगर वाइल्ड ट्रू लुक भी चला सकते हो ठीक
है ना
याद रखना की क्वेश्चंस आप जैसे अगर आपने
10 क्वेश्चन इंटर किया तो ये नहीं की आप
वहां पर दाल रहे हो की 11 क्वेश्चंस
तो उसके लिए भी उसके लिए भी आपको एक ये
इसके अंदर खामियां है मेरी पकड़ में मैं
खाने ही जानता हूं क्या-क्या खामियां मेरे
प्रोग्राम के अंदर तो वो खामियां आपको
पुरी करनी है और इसको और भी अगर आप
इंप्रूव कर सको तो इंप्रूव करके
आपको क्या करना है कुछ भी नहीं करना है
आपको नॉर्मल ही अपना
लिंग के अंदर जान का है
लिंकडइन में जान के बाद में
कम करता हूं पहले तो इसको लाइक करके आप
लोग भी ऐसे ही करना
भूल गया था ठीक है
तो अपने पेज पर जाना है लिंकडइन के अंदर
पोस्ट के अंदर जाना
जान के बाद में यह दे सिक्स का जैसा आया
तो वैसे दे सेवन का भी ए जाएगा प्रोजेक्ट
का तो उसके नाम पर कमेंट में क्या-क्या
बताना है क्या-क्या बताना है आपको की
रेंडम लाइब्रेरी के बड़े में जो कुछ भी अब
जान दो और आपने वो इशू वेलकम कैसे किया है
वो भी आप उसका भी कोड स्क्रीनशॉट उसकी
गूगल ड्राइव पे फाइल अपलोड करके डालो कुछ
भी करो लेकिन यहां पर लिख दो की कैसे हुआ
है अगर आप लोगों से नहीं हो का रहे हैं अब
आप पहले आपको ट्राई करना है ट्राई होने के
बाद नहीं हो पाते तो वो टेलीग्राम पर आना
पूछना जरूरी उसके रेस्पॉन्ड किया जाएगा
ऐसे लेक आप ट्राई नहीं कर रहे हो और हां
जो आपने ट्राई किया है वो तो उसका
स्क्रीनशॉट है क्या ट्राई किया वो मुझे
बताना पड़ेगा आपको उसके बाद ही आपको मैं
सॉल्यूशन प्रोवाइड करूंगा ठीक है
तो यही था आज के अपने प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर
पहले तो मुझे चाट करना होता है की आप
लोगों को प्रोजेक्ट लगा के सर जब तक मेरा
थोड़ा सा लोड कर देता हूं जो मेरा
स्टार्टिंग वाली इमेज
कोई भी प्रेजेंटेशन नहीं बनाई है
प्रोजेक्ट कैसा लगा आप लोगों को
वेटिंग
कुछ यूनिक था की नहीं है मतलब आप यह चाहे
तो अपने कॉलेज मतलब सेकेंडरी बता सकते हो
की आप यह ऐसे बट आपके ही जो क्लासमेट हैं
वह आपको ही डटेंगे की तुमने ऐसा प्रोग्राम
क्यों दिया कॉलेज वालों को अब तो हमारे
रेड लेंगे सबको अलग-अलग क्वेश्चंस मिलेंगे
बट आप लोग पटेली करने के लिए महाराष्ट्र
में तो पटेली बोलते हैं इसको राजस्थान में
वो शारीरिक करने के लिए और आपकी शर्ट में
जैसे बोलते हैं इसको वैसे आप समझ जो
बट जो बट जो भी लोग कर रहे थे वह बता दो
कौन-कौन लोग कर रहे थे
नॉर्मल सा एकदम तो थैंक यू
पूरा 7 डेज तक कैसा लगा एक बार प्लीज मुझे
कमेंट में बता दो और मैं टेलीग्राम के
अंदर भी फोल्डर दाल दूंगा आपको 7 डेज तक
कैसा लगा अच्छा रिस्पांस ए जाएगा तो मैं
जरूर कोई दूसरी बकरा भी नहीं लैंग्वेज के
ऊपर या डेवलपमेंट के ऊपर जरूर लेकर आऊंगा
प्रोजेक्ट अगर आपको अच्छे लगे तो इसके
अलावा मतलब ये तो बहुत बेसिक समय बताना
सबसे लोएस्ट मतलब ये मैं बता रहा हूं ना
मैंने ये वाला प्रोजेक्ट मेरे 11वीं में
किया था अभी मैं सेकंड एयर के अंदर हूं तो
सोचो की मैं बस अभी तक मैं कितने और
प्रोजेक्ट अच्छे से होंगे तो अगर आप लोग
कोई अच्छा लगा मेरा तो अपन और भी प्रदेश
वगैरा करेंगे आपके डिमांड पर कर सकते हैं
आप लोग टेलीग्राम एक्टिव रहिए आप बताइए
क्या ऐसा प्रोजेक्ट मेरे दिमाग में है अगर
आप लोग चाहते हैं तो प्लीज आप लोग अपना
यहां पर टेलीग्राम में बता सकते हो की सर
ये वाला
टूल मेरे दिमाग में है जो कहानी अवेलेबल
नहीं है की आप इसको एक्सक्यूज कर सकते हैं
तो जरूर इसको जरूर किया जाएगा
अगर अच्छा अच्छा लगेगा तो आइडिया
स्टार्टिंग के अंदर तो अब प्रोजेक्ट
मुझे बता दो की यार भाई आपने वो कैसे किया
था
देखो
ना तो ये वीडियो दो ढाई घंटे की जाति है
तो उसे चक्कर में बहुत जल्दी हो जाता है
इसीलिए मेरे को ज्यादा डर तक भी बैठे रहते
हैं तो फिर एकदम गढ़वाली बोलते हैं भाई
क्या कर रहा है मतलब मेरे नहीं आप लोग के
बोलेंगे मैं तो कहानी और राहत हूं
चलो बढ़िया है टीचिंग स्टाइल कैसा लगा मदद
अच्छा लगा कुछ चाहिए
अपने को इस क्वेश्चन पेपर को बनाने के लिए
थैंक यू फ्रेंड्स इसको मैं कैसे बटर
बनाऊंगा अगर आप वो भी बता डॉग तो मिलने
बहुत अच्छा होगा
स्टार्टिंग के टेस्ट में हां मतलब फर्स्ट
दे में थोड़ा सा मैं
बीमा था फर्स्ट दे वाले दिन इससे कर के
अंदर फर्स्ट दे थोड़ा सा मेरे को हड़बड़ी
में निकालना पड़ा बट सेकंड डेज से थोड़ा
सा सही होना चालू होगा
चलो कोई नहीं अपन और अच्छे से बातें बातें
करेंगे टेलीग्राम के अंदर आपको और भी कुछ
प्रोग्रामिंग से रिलेटेड या कुछ भी
रिलेटेड चीजों से अगर बातें बातें करनी है
तो आई एम ऑलवेज देवर बजट बस एक बार टैग कर
देना क्योंकि मैं टेलीग्राम पे इतना नहीं
राहत हूं बट हां
चलिए थैंक यू
जय हिंद वंदे मातरम
#